(light soft music)
- [Narrator] In this small town outside
of Mumbai there's a school.
And in this school are adorable grannies.
This is India's first
school for grandmothers.
(upbeat music)
Every day elderly women come
to a school called Aajibaichi Shala
for the education they missed
out on earlier in life.
(speaking in a foreign language)
Because most girls weren't
allowed to go to school
they could only dream of an education.
(speaking in a foreign language)
Unable to sign their names
to important documents
their whole lives, the women show off
their signature with great pride today.
And for most of them,
getting to attend school
is one of the best parts of their day.
(speaking in a foreign language)
Though the school for grannies
is only a one year program,
many of the women have plans
to continue their education.
(speaking in a foreign language)
(light soft music)